what is the biggest challenge to
transition from you're here protecting
saving lives on the front line you're
getting shot up seeing people you're
seeing some difficult things I mean
chaos non-stop to transition into
civilian
I think there's a lot of job skills
obviously like if you're if you're a
team leader in an infantry unit and
you're making Dynamic decisions while
getting shot at you you already have
such a leadership sensibility about you
that absolutely applies the civilian
sector for me it was the the cultural
change from the military right because
all of a sudden I had to deal with
[ __ ] feelings and that's the truth
whereas when I'm overseas and you're
working with a very professional team
you know we we have the most
edgy jokes to each other but we all know
that you we got each other's backs and
there and for me coming into the
civilian sector that was the hardest
part because all of a sudden I had to
like worry about a pronoun like straight
up and and for me it really messed with
my head and it was the whole reason I
went back overseas because I wanted to
be around people like me that could make
jokes make her be a little reverent and
then that kind of metabolized into me
saying hey I'm gonna start my own
businesses because I can choose
culturally who's a part of that and I
want to work with fun exciting educated
people that want to crush life I don't
want to work with people that want to be
victims and that's what I found a lot in
the civilian sector and I'm not paying
that for everybody I'm just simply
saying Corporate America has been
conditioned like that or especially the
last 10 years it's gotten so much worse
so if we had the opportunity to create a
culture and hire veterans that believe
in the stuff we believe in and give them
you know a safe space in a way of in a
reverent terms kind of the opposite of a
space space where people can wear their
tattoos say the f word like let's just
get work done and treat people well and
do you ask that in the interview process
like or do you are you more I'm actually
really curious because you guys have
built a very very successful brand
company I mean you guys are killing it
it's not a small thing that you guys are
building you guys have done a great job
with the company so is it you use a
recruiting firm that specifically
focuses on talent and culture and you
tell them these are the five things
we're looking for if you come here or do
you guys in the interview process
specifically ask certain questions that
filters out people that maybe won't fit
your culture what's that process yeah I
think it always starts with the top
right so you have a CHR or whoever
you're you know head of Human Resources
is like that comes from the founders and
the executive staff as far as hey these
are the things and the attributes that
we want in someone and it's almost like
uh back in the intelligence Community
you rather have someone has a tssei
clearance and then train them how to do
a profession because the clearance is
the hardest part the culture in business
for me is the hardest part once you see
someone and you know okay they might not
have the exact skill set that we need
quite yet but we can put a professional
development plan together and then
honestly I like that because especially
if they're a veteran we're providing
them a structure to succeed learn a new
skill and they already have their
leadership experience they have the
culture experience now it's just a
matter of like how do I roast coffee
that's that's a pretty easy skill and
we're giving them a new skill so it's
all in I think the format of who you're
looking for and and the culture aspect
of the employee side is is a very large
thing for me at least got it so it's up
front so if I'm if I'm going through the
interview process I'm already gonna know
what it's going to entail to be part of
Black Rifle coffee yeah and and let's be
honest a lot of it and maybe doesn't
even need to come from us because if you
look at the company and you go on and
look at the videos and you watch coming
out as a conservative you referenced
that earlier
you have a pretty good indicator of what
my values are and what the company's
values are so
you either like it you don't know a lot
of people don't like it and they don't
come work for it have you ever had
people that don't agree with your values
that work with you guys and we're
successful uh I'm sure yeah I mean they
probably were quiet about it a little
bit how big are you guys at this point
how big is uh over a thousand employees
a thousand employees got it about 50
veteran High rate in that too no [ __ ] 50
yeah props to you right around there
first of all thank you for your service
and thank you for hiring vets the way
you are 50 yeah I mean that's what we
set out to do and we're not done I mean
this is just the start to be honest with
you so what's the vision what's the
Grand Vision what are we going to be
doing all of us going to be drinking
coffee one day hopefully I saw some
other coffee back there in the The Green
Room I have to change that out this is
weak bro this is not your call I'm not
drinking it I was expecting maybe a gift
or something bro I don't just well it's
in the mail I promise okay
um no I mean we made a promise to our
customer base we're gonna hire 10 000
veterans years ago and um that has been
at the Forefront of our of our our
journey this entire time and you start
to see that a lot more with some of the
brick and mortar locations opening and a
lot of other the Strategic Partnerships
that were we're doing like partnering
with Dallas Cowboys stuff like that so
it's it's always who loves you who hates
you who loves Black Rifle coffee who
hates Black Rifle coffee I mean a lot of
people love us and a lot of people hate
us you know we've been in the we've been
in a culture War a few times during it
um so we're we're not shy to uh yeah a
little a little hate in the internet but
I'm okay with it yeah it is what it is
speaking of haters you guys since uh
whatever deal you put together with the
Dallas Cowboys made a lot of news yeah
what was that what was the drama with
all that especially with the the recent
string of mass shootings or school
shootings that was kind of in the news
it's an emotional position from woke
media in my opinion because when I look
at this and I look I look at it like
battle space back in the military of
like who's taking shots and why are they
taking shots well
they're trying to rip away like people
that just love America and that's where
I started because it's America's team in
America's coffee so when a lot of people
somehow based off of us having Black
Rifle coffee in our company's name tried
to use that and sensationalize that into
saying that somehow it was distasteful
because the national tragedy happened
and then a football company and a coffee
company are partnering I don't
understand was it the timing is that
what it was yeah but I mean when is but
that was months and months ahead right
so it is what it is if people want to
get offended at that hey it is yeah I
think I think you need to be
congratulated for doing a deal with
Jerry Jones that's that's the epitome I
mean that is phenomenal that's going to
pay huge benefits let me ask you this
Matt um you're not that far removed from
the military what are people telling you
as far as the walkification of the
military is that real I mean have are
they changing
yeah I mean we we've have talked about
this over the years it seems from a lot
of my friends
um not every unit but there are specific
units and the cultures that have been
changing because when you have a lot
more Progressive leadership that comes
into the White House and and other
portions of of the country their
influence over generals and Admirals and
and name the brass that top down right
top down comes from culture and yeah I I
don't know this whole like mandatory
vaccination thing in the military I mean
it seems as we're just trying to create
a weak Force which is like the opposite
of being a Warfighter like it's okay to
have tattoos and you're going out on
target with your friends too
killer capture high value targets like
that's a real job and it's you need
people that signed up for that because
I'm trying to be very uh casual with my
statements there but the whole purpose
of being in the military is is to fight
Wars and win them but I think man's men
are making a big comeback I think it's
coming back and I think people are uh uh
sit and run and saying what the hell are
you talking about by the way you know
who's going to help men's men make a
comeback women it's going to be where a
lot of like you had a you had a you had
a girl on on your podcast it was like
listen this is what I'm looking for for
man I want to be able to do this I want
a man that does this where they're
looking for more Alphas of men who are
willing to step up and take the lead
rather than being you know pansies
walking around thinking they have to
please everybody and and I think it is
making a comeback so I don't think
that's going to slow down so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]